[Music]
[Music]
hello
is everything okay
you have mascara fell over your whole
face you actually have
like a piece of toilet paper
other side there yeah just got dumped i
want to break up with you what
oh me too i'm breaking up with you
oh
my god
what about this whatever we're feeling
like we just can't take it anymore
let's kill each other
for each other's sadness sisters well
sadness sister sounds like you're dying
keaton and i'm meryl streep and we're in
a broadway play but oh i get yeah that's
a great cast
you should cast please
oh my god and look at her with my
boyfriend this is bad
what the [ __ ]
he was the love of my life and is the
love of mine but i'm not so sure that
they're gonna realize it not with these
shiny new people around what are we
supposed to do
i have to break them up that's crazy we
can't do that
how would we do that
[Music]
i will seduce anne's boyfriend am i
doing this right so what you just take
your two fingers let it drip out oh
thank you
i don't think we've met hi oh
you will friendship seduce noah
what about your ex really funny was she
funny hop that you're not i'd rather not
i'll tell you what i'll take mine off
too that's not gonna help me at all
can i tell you a little secret about
being an adult
all just pretending that we know what
we're doing and we're hoping that we
don't screw it up
your stamina has really improved it's
the drugs i find you both incredibly
attractive oh yeah
wow look at you good work yeah man i'm a
psycho
[Music]
you are somebody that a person could
fall very deeply in love with
but it's more like slowly
over five or six months okay for like a
year
two years top do you realize the
number's going up
[Applause]
[Music]
you